I am NOT here to entertain you today I
don't have the capacity to do that right
now I am here it was one regular human
being to another because I am not happy
right now
I am not happy with myself and I need to
talk to someone about it I just haven't
been the best version of myself recently
I said that I had ambitions to try make
films but I've been making incredibly
slow progress on the short film that
I've been trying to write over the
course of the last year in regards to my
youtube channel not only am I not
posting content as regularly as I want
to and know that I can cuz I've done it
well enough in the past but I also don't
think the stuff I've been making
recently is just as good as it used to
be and that just makes me really sad and
the worst part of it for me is that I am
trying incredibly hard to be the person
that I want to be again but every time I
sit and stare at that blank text file
ready to try and come up with something
new I find myself terrified to create
like genuinely scared and the thing that
I'm scared of I honestly I think it's
you I think I am scared of you now and
that's faux could we need to fix that I
realized this recently when I sat down
to try and work out why I do anything
really why anybody does anything and the
best answer I could come up with is that
every person deep down whether they are
willing to admit it or not just they
want other people to like them and
that's all it's ever been for me before
YouTube for me it was magic tricks I
used to go around school with a magnet
up my sleeve and I would make coins
disappear out of people's hands and I
did it because it impressed people and
that made me feel cool and given the
incredibly shy kid that I was back then
was a huge deal for me then YouTube
happened and I started to feel better
about myself than I ever have in my
entire life because people liked me
all of a sudden more people than I could
ever hope to impress at school doing
magic tricks and my confidence boosted
to highs that I had never experienced
before but over the course of the last
year whatever confidence I had left is
dwindled away to practically nothing
when I try and make stuff nowadays what
holds me back isn't the idea that maybe
it's not going to be very good it
maybe you won't like it and the by
extension you won't like me and so I run
away which is what I like to do when I
am scared I run and I don't do anything
at all and I really wish that wasn't the
truth because I can't escape the idea
that me wanting other people to like me
is somehow weak and that I should just
make whatever I want to make and not
care about what anyone else thinks of me
but I can't help but care about what you
think because worrying whatever people
think of me has been my whole life I
spend almost every day being anxious
about what my peers think of me you know
what are the conversations that they
have about me when I'm not in the room
what are the flaws of mine that they
have noticed but would never dare to
point out to me and do they even talk
about me at all
is another one like do they even care
enough to disgust me that's what the
inside of my brain looks like my hope is
that this is just what it's like to be
human that everybody secretly just feels
the same way as me just as anxious as I
do about other people but I don't know
that for sure and I don't know what to
do about this either like the simplest
answer to me is that I should just stop
caring about it so much but I have no
idea how to do that all I want to do
with my life is make and do things that
make other people happy I can't think of
a better way to spend my time on this
planet but right now I I just have to
hope I guess that I have the capacity
within myself to be that person that I
want to be because right now I just
don't know I am unsure and that scares
me a lot if you have been thank you for
sticking with me over the course of this
last year I really appreciate it more
than anything else
truly um and thank you for listening to
me
bye you've just had the almost
imponderable joy of watching Charlie is
so cool like which makes you like cool